focus japan mit globetrotter am
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
waldweg globetrotters punkt ch
[Musik]
letzte ausfahrt kurz nach dem 4
ich bin mir sicher dass sie viel woche
bin ich als fotograf und journalist
japan unterwegs
ich betrachte das buch zu machen aber
das land
[Musik]
ich lehre die männer kennt rosanna rocci
dann auf den meisterteller von der
weniger tempels japan russland hat sein
lehrer
ich mache einen kreis und den stein
du machst den äußeren in verbindung dazu
darum alle menschen sind verwaltungen
öffnet das herz
nichts ist für die ewigkeit ich kann ein
neues muster machen wenn ich wählen
jede tätigkeit ist in sich perfekt wenn
man die ganze energie auf den augenblick
lenkt das wichtigste ist dass selbst man
wendet sich dem inneren des selbst zudem
waren selbst mit dieser spirituellen
gesunden haltung bringt man den körper
atmung und den geist in ordnung geist
und körper genießen
diese drei punkte zu trainieren
das macht das leben mit seinen aus
[Musik]
die stäbchen aus gefühle und platziert
sie rechts dann öffnet die servierten
nehmt die schüsselchen mit der linken
hand von links her der francesco rosi
gencer gratis westliche psyche trägern
im ten soll nix gedanken ablehnte darum
ist die messe alle stränge ritualisiert
jetzt die nächste schüssel
[Musik]
bitte es schneller und still
bitte nicht den rettich essen
legt die stäbchen nicht hin egal was
passiert
es den rettich reinigt die schnäppchen
liegt sie zurück in die hülle trinkt das
wasser will das ist die zehn weise zu
speisen
alles wird genau und bewusst gemacht das
ist etwas vom wichtigsten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir wachsen andere daten von roche
genscher
[Musik]
hier machen sich meditation langsam und
videos das soll helfen
also wird es hier und jetzt kann der
kunstlehrer doch so einfach ist das gar
nicht ich frage mich was daraus gemacht
und ich befürchte dass ich mich aufs
nächste treffen dort sachlich
ich rufe staus und bin auch im lange
setzte plötzlich recht entspannt sammelt
sich die kraft beim tandem dem zentrum
des körpers
hier kommt die kraft her sein zentrum
ist schlaf ein tandem sollst du stärken
damit eine willenskraft und energie
fließen kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
manpower ist das spirituelle bewusstsein
mit allem verbunden zu sein ich zeige
dir die innere kraft mit meinem körper
so ist diese ski leichter zu verstehen
und dann drosch erfüllung durch sätze
wie schwer bist du dann demonstrierte
branche das heißt wenn die ganze energie
im zentrum von kabul hat wenn man
richtig atmet und geistig wach ist wird
man sich seine prächtigen seele bewusst
und entwickelt sich das auch meint
fornas achtsamkeit das wichtigste band
sehen ist sein zentrum zu finden
vier tagen
[Musik]
die fotos hatte mal wieder mehr verdient
und ich war jetzt muenchen idee post
sein bedeutet
[Musik]
volkert und mini suite darauf aus ak
start dieses als handelszentrum und eis
vor der wichtigste industrie der hofer
versagt ist eine vor der wichtigste im
land
[Musik]
außer kraft ob die erste sekunde
statisch sehr lang irgendwo weniger
hektisch aus tokio manches im entspannt
und recht witzig
[Musik]
jung in handschellen tragen
und so wie 83 auf drei mann auf der
anderen seite von glos stand finde ich
dass das symbol es ist frei
[Musik]
ich kann nämlich japanerinnen und
japaner der sich immer weniger binden
immer mehr labrang stimmbezirke warum
das so ist heute morgen in ebendieser
gewinner
[Musik]
frei auf das ist auch normal sind warten
dem asset beraterin man das gefühl hat
dass gabriel mit seiner vorfreude passt
dann bringt sie zu ihm
ich würde einfach fotografieren mit
ihrer rede
ich dachte okay sich eine dritte konzert
um nichts mehr als ein jahrzehnt ist das
schwierig hier einen mann zu finden
es ist schwierig den ersten eindruck
richtig einzuschätzen
familien mit kindern
zwei wären perfekt
sind sie nervös an einem solchen abend
ja ich bin aufgeregt dass in grove und
zog vor zwei frauen am nebentisch hatte
zueinander gefunden woran die bosse für
20 minuten lautet frauen und
männerbilder sitze spanischen dann fällt
immer wieder traf oder nicht wenn es bis
der nicht weiß wird sowieso nix ist
haute gehen ist es entscheidend
man ziehe komisch düstere telefonnummer
oder mehr geld zurück zum manager der
gene eines feedback zum treffer wie der
nordlys coach setzte man da im april
dann aber auf der suche nach liebe
heiraten ja der möglicherweise schichten
ja wir sind japaner sitzt im 90
wann der manager schenk und
wirtschaftskrise hat das land ja bis gar
bringt die gastgeber und eine zahl
[Musik]
das wochen anwärter vermutlich werden
allein zu verbringen
[Musik]
warum haben sie heute abend keinen mann
gefunden wurden
[Musik]
warum wohl
heutzutage ist es schwieriger jemanden
am arbeitsplatz kennen zu lernen
wegen der vielen überstunden hat man
kaum zeit leute zu treffen und solche
orte wie hier gehören zu den wenigen
gelegenheiten denke juni ist gekommen
weil sie von freunden gehört hat die
hier früher einmal ihren partner
gefunden haben und sicher wieder zurück
kommt platz im august getroffen hat herr
geht's waren über die strahlung aber
irgendwie hätte es nicht richtig die
post ihre synchronisation sehr wichtig
und er denkt sprach hergiswil pause
gegangen
das verzerrt zum single manager jetzt in
rolle als couch schwerin ist was haben
sie von manager gelernt
[Musik]
angst hat auf das äußere zu schauen
sollte ich auf meine gefühle für diese
person achten gefühle sind wichtiger als
das aussehen
[Musik]
shingo welchen rat würden die
japanischen männern geben und welchen
japanischen frauen männer tauschen zwar
die kontaktinformationen aus aber sie
sind so tollpatschig in der darauf
folgenden kommunikation frauen urteilen
viel zu schnell
frauen müssten sich nach diesen treffen
mindestens noch zu einem dinner
verabredet und so dem man noch ein
bisschen besser kennen lernen
bis vor nicht allzu langer zeit hat
japan vor allem arrangierte hochzeit
dagegen liebesheirat sind in sachsen ist
das anders
aber mit der freiheit sendung aussteigen
bevor drücken
[Musik]
ein großer modernisierungsschub hat
japan ihm zur 70
dort macht wirtschaft regelrecht
explodiert aber dort soll eine große
veränderung hat tradition hersteller war
kaperte tradition und moderne ganz sogar
stündlich gehört sie auch im vierten
versuch mit
er beherrscht als jahrhundertgenie
[Musik]
geschnitzt moschitz lothar das ist ein
700 jahre alte theater forum wo sie
gebraucht es mit verändert hat alle
rollen waren von meiner spielen was für
die figuren sich erkannt man hat am 8
sie sind zentrale element im notiert
je nachdem wie das auch spieler der kopf
habt daran wird sich alexis druck von
einem us crew bedeutet der maske einen
traurigen ausdruck zu verleihen
und wenn man sie so nach oben richtet
dann bekommt sie einen helleren ausdruck
ein beispiel
hier habe ich ein gesicht auf das
gefaltete papier gezeichnet so etwas
ähnliches macht man auch mit der no mas
[Musik]
ich würde dir so matschig oder
fotografiert am liebsten mit natürlichem
licht damit mir die schöne stimme in
seinem atelier auf der bilder wirksam
aber gebraucht mich 15 jahre lang
welcher lehrgang zum fußballlehrer zwei
jahre später zum ersten mal selber
alaska für schnitzel und er nach 40
jahren ohne die arbeit jetzt schon macht
machte sie immer noch mit großer hingabe
ich habe den letzten wochen auf unserer
reise gelernt dass man in japan sein
wahres gesicht nicht zeigt wie stark
denken sie herrn matschie dass jetzt
diese neue kunst der wind hat es ja
typisch japanisch ist auch ist sein
wahres gesicht zu verbergen
[Musik]
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man so
direkt an in bezug herstellen kann
zwischen nun dieser japanischen
gewohnheit
aber es gab einen historisch wichtigen
no spieler dessen lehre lautete man soll
etwas nicht aktiv explizite erstellen
sondern implizit spüren dass zum
beispiel gibt es beim auftreten auf der
bühne eine haltung bei der die maske
einen bestimmten winkel hat wenn man
diesen winkel auch nur ganz sanft
verändert wird etwas ausgedrückt
darstellungsweise ist also sehr
eingeschränkt post no aber doch zu york
bonn
um vieles nie zeit sondern erfülle damit
man versteht
er hatte
[Musik]
würden sie für mich eine solche maske
vors gesicht halten die fertigen 100
stunden schaffte ja sotschi an eine
maske das wichtigste sei dass jede maske
eine perfekte kopie von vergangenen ist
das künstlerische freiheit einer
interpretation das vertriebs nicht nur
kunst natürlich würde ich jetzt die
masken lokalen umsatz gesehen
sie vermittelt mir in psyche im kongo
theater
[Musik]
regie konko 14 sachse zwanzigster
generation schöne vorfahrer hält das vor
150 jahren gegründet ich kann nicht viel
gesehen
die maske muss ich gut polstern wenn sie
stundenlang trage behandelt
chinas nationale wurde die autobranche
720 generation führt wird sich jetzt
gerade frei
es ist nur von der probe aber trotzdem
sehr aufwändig
[Musik]
tradition seit dem moment wo der spieler
massiv setzte fördergeld von der figur
innen drin
[Musik]
notiert ist genau festgelegt sind
jahrhunderte
[Musik]
sie verstecken ihr gesicht hinter einer
maske müssen ihr gesicht verstecken
hinter einer maske wird dafür ein
schauspieler nicht etwas ganz wichtiges
[Musik]
es gibt auch bei welchen man keine maske
getragen wird
aber auch dort muss die mimik des
schauspielers neutral bleiben das wird
unter maske genannt das eigene gesicht
wird dann gewissermaßen als maske
getragen fühlen werden also nie über die
mimik ausgedrückt es ist eher etwas das
aus dem tiefen inneren heraus kommt
[Musik]
sehr spezielle theaterform wo nicht
heben wir nicht ganz verstehen
ob ich bin oft von der eleganz
[Musik]
vor sacra flüge auf okinawa treibt
händlern ganze gruppe von ihrer insel
und fahrt die sich 200 kilometer weiter
im süden
[Musik]
das klima zum kino war es tropisch ich
komm ich beruf biohof das heißt ich
glaube schafe und darf dafür bittet
bürger wohnen
[Musik]
stürmisch aber bislang rund 19
ich habe den richtigen ort gefunden
ich freue mich sie kennenzulernen
ich bin mal auf den ersten blick war's
mit der kick off erzählt hiesige
vertreter jahr von der halbinsel auf
okinawa zeuge ihre qual ist ja besser
als auf estland japan
manche siege offeneren entspannter sie
haben ein zimmer für gäste normalerweise
haben wir jeweils eine person dieses
unkraut musste schneiden gibt es
gefährliche tiere deshalb machst du am
besten so bevor du anfängst danke los
geht's
mit einer rostigen idee der firma
tropische hitze ich falle eine hohe
preismacht
[Musik]
- familie ist keine richtige pro familie
der kiko ist ursprüngliche system
schafft aber neben offenburg und der
mann abel ist kramer künstler
er hat vor allem wagen gehörte le mans
fokkena wallach
[Musik]
der boden ist nicht nur bei einem
lebensalter sehr fruchtbar zurückbuchen
wie verrückt
[Musik]
die amis sind wie viele menschen zog ihn
aber selbstversorger auf abschluss von
der gartenarbeit starken
frühlingszwiebel ist 14482 sind geheim
das ist das okinawa küchengerät cherry
cherry wie heißt das ohne blutvergießen
du kannst kann ich den rest essen ja ja
ein kubanischer nicht unterstrich
japanische riester gehört die sprache
der schwierigen aber manche hier fühlen
sich als opfer
früher war es ein eigenständiges
königreich dann wurde es für japan
annektiert und die menschen verloren
ihre identität japan gegen japan hatte
china war immer diskriminiert und opera
war war im zweiten weltkrieg der einzige
ort wo ein land gekämpft wurde
die amerikaner haben nicht auf der
hauptinsel gekämpft sie gingen nicht
nach tokio
sie haben es nur bombardiert die
amerikaner haben dann für ihre militär
basen den einheimischen land weggenommen
und sind geblieben
neben der geschichte fühlen sich die
menschen auf okinawa doppelt als opfer
betrogen und benutzt so fühlt sich vor
allem die ältere generation
wegen dieser empfindung proteste die
ältere generation gegen die us präsenz
aber es ändert sich nichts
das hat mit oper theater und am schluss
ist doch so richtig politisch wurde
[Musik]
laut materie ganzen gruppe demonstranten
buchforst basis blockiere china kommen
übersetzerin weiß mehr
heute morgen ist die polizei bereits vor
ort nennen stunde wird sie beginnen den
platz zu räumen
ich habe das gar nicht vorstellen ist
eine andere sätze mit der polizei
friedliche japan
wo man normalerweise nicht maschine
wenig seit das ist doch recht düster
kleinlich
sicherheits lied von der militärbasis in
zurückhaltend die demonstranten machen
dass sie 20 jahren
und dann kamen zwei polizisten sie war
etwas was wir da machen zu stellen mit
wie sie traten vor bedankt
auskunft und verabschieden sich
freundlich doch dann fort politik
geschützt
so geld dafür jeder polizist dem ruf
damit lastwagen endlich auf buch stellt
jede minute war dominic raacke und vita
buch kostet genau auswählen
demonstranten will immer wieder soldaten
freie belästigen entschied natur kaputt
machen aber manche zur kinder war
anständig und die plötzlich ziel für
angriffe
nordkorea ist nicht weit entfernt
[Musik]
manchen öfteren ins lateinische sehr
viel durchgemacht da vor allem die ganz
alte mallorquiner berichten und für
einen gc
[Musik]
so gibt es dort von der 100 jährige
das heißt auf und davon und die älteste
mannschaft aber ich habe mit herrn
magath macht studierte vorzeichen
was halten sie von den entwicklungen der
letzten jahrzehnte in japan und china
war unter der kontrolle der japanischen
regierung waren wir immer arm sei die
amerikaner hier sind sind wir reicher ja
ich bin dankbar und glücklich dass sie
uns beschützen wie sie jeden tag züchtig
unter anderem goya das typische gesunde
gemüse hier entferne die insekten und
schnecken aus meinem garten das ist mein
morgendliches fitnesstraining
[Gelächter]
was denken sie über die jungen leute
heutzutage gehen alle gleichen spital
wenn sie ein wenig fieber hat man jetzt
in kinder waren ihm später wir hatten
kein geld für so was ich machte ihnen
ein getränk mit wildkräutern und zucker
das senkt das fieber das fieber gilt
auch wenn man bananenblätter ausgelegt
wie ein kissen und machten werden
slavica china wandelt sich viola ob man
nicht nur einfluss aus dem westen
traditionen kampf verloren alles im
garten ist gemüse das kannst du es
naja
[Gelächter]
ich esse das immer
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das lied jetzt rogy wie so alt waren und
hat verschiedene gründe so unter
nachtisch eine aber jetzt klima und die
gute soziale vernetzung durch händler
großen fluss einmal in der woche treffen
sich die älteste frau der welt in
gemeinsamem vorgehen
hier kann am jagen und ihre kolleginnen
als und hitler jagger
das projekt nicht nur alt sondern gesund
auto und rannte mit seiner haare dass
man hier auf der insel nach dem
grundsatz haare hachiko und hachiko
heißt füllt in den büchern nur zu 80
prozent mehr chance und seiten her
sprichst du japanisch verstehst du ja
panik
als ich jung war war ich sehr hübsch und
meine haut war wunderschön so alt bin
ich jetzt ich bin jetzt 90 du schwitzt
komme nicht trocknet ich etwas ab mit
dem taschentuch
ich bin fotograf
das verleitet sachlichkeit verlassen
[Musik]
was meinen sie zur kann aber der
abschiedsfahrt man ganz ehrlich zeit
nicht leicht
ich glaube trotzdem winter normal mit
richtiger 430 kilometer und zwar auf die
insel ishigaki war ganz in der nähe von
taiwan lenkert
[Musik]
hauptsächlich um nächste mal oder
tumoren er hat mir zeit der mauer hängen
ganz andere geschichte das sind
traditionelle bot wo ganz aus holz
gemacht sind und da gibt es keine metall
schrauben oder nägel wenn du metall
nagel verwendest werden die nach 22
jahren rostig und es bildet sich einfach
rundherum der nagel wird lose und fällt
raus
ein bambus stift hingegen wird eins mit
dem holz des bootes solange das ganze
holz hält kannst das gut benutzen wenn
ein stück bricht kann ich es heraussägen
und ein neues stück einfügen
[Musik]
der hund ursprüngliches tokio da hat
einen ganz schönen beruf schaffen kann
aber richtig frieden ihr gesehen
irgendwann ist alles viel wurde und
beschlossen
mit seiner familie hat er ist weiter
[Musik]
sie hat wohl gelernt und traut die
boards macht hat ihm gezeigt
endlich
[Musik]
der sand beach paar meter hinter dem
haus leckeren tomohiro sie zeigen das
aber nicht verlangen
[Musik]
mehr
casio hat sich zunehmend verändert seit
du hier lebst während ich in tokio
arbeitete um eine familie zu ernähren
versteifte sich meine innere haltung ich
merkte ich arbeite um zu überleben ohne
arbeit kein leben ohne geld keine ihr
auf die partie änderte sich meine
mentalität dann langsam
es funktioniert auch anders und einfach
der natur und warum erhält man ja wasser
und man kann nahrung anbauen damit an
essen und überleben kann
die dinge sind da und du kannst anfangen
zu leben und hast zeit für die familie
was muss ich wissen bevor ich ins wasser
springen macht druckausgleich wenn du
kannst du das
[Musik]
auf youtube
ich verstehe was thomas meint wenn er
seit er hier mädchen frei kämen und
weiterhin das paradies gefunden
persönlicher größer doch das doppelte
oder ist hier auf ishigaki geboren
es gibt kaum einschränkungen wir können
unsere familien selber gestalten
nachbarn sind wie eine erweiterte
familie wir sind glücklich
[Musik]
wenn ich das richtig sehe hast du heute
zwar weniger aber deine leben ist viel
besser
das stimmt ich finde glück hängt nicht
vom anhäufen von vielen dingen ab
ein neuer fokus wie mache ich mein leben
reicher wie kann ich eine tiefere
erfüllung finden mit dem was ich habe
das mache man viel glücklicher
ich bin vor bald sechs wochen los
gezogen
eine fotokamera japans entdecken und
zwar immer so ständig hand
miss teen spirit machen aber das land
und china sei es so viele verschiedene
menschen begegnet minister erwartet
die hemmenden blick in ihre schlappe
japan wahrscheinlich trotzdem immer
freunde bleiben aber der verstand nach
der reise doch schon mit besser und da
ist weiß ich ganz sicher ich will mit
der droge irgendwo der 43 hat das land
die menschen gebracht
[Musik]
focus japan mit globetrotter am
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte die
reise bald wied globetrotters punkt ch